vous reconnaissez ce monuments les
hospices de bon emblématique de la ville
mais ce serait oublié qu'ici beaucoup
d'édifices ou beaucoup de monuments
témoignent de la richesse de BA et puis
de son évolution au cours de l'histoire
pour vous en donner une petite idée je
vous propose une balade à travers
quelquesuns de ces monuments et avec un
guide qui connaît très bien ce
patrimoine
voilà c'était ici que habita les ducs de
Bourgogne avant d'être avant d'être à
dij ici à
bon alors là c'est typiquement une
maison du du du
Moyen-Âge le rechaussé il est en pierre
et l'étage il est constitué de de P de
bois et entre les deux tu vois il y a
cette petite galerie qui est
encorbellement elle est en porte à faau
par rapport r de-chaussée et ça les
maisons au moyen très courant qu' soit
comme
ça ça c'est l'hôtel de la rochepau et
c'est un immeuble qui est intéressant
parce qu'il montre la transition entre
le Moyen-âge et la Renaissance donc là
il y a une
façade qui est tout à fait
représentative de l'architecture la fin
de l'architecture
à l'intérieur il y a une cour qui tu vas
voir complètement
différente c'est la Renaissance c'est
1500 c'est juste après on a complètement
changé d'architecture ça éque l'Italie
on voyage la Renaissance c'est le goût
pour l'Antiquité et
l'Italie il y a
notamment les colonnes qui superposent
les C sur BC c'est une architecture un
peu parfaite très
géométrique quelque chose d' en av
beaucoup on est dans dans la chapelle de
l'ancien couvent des
visitesandines voilà et cette chapelle
donc décorée plutôt au 18e siècle avec
une architecture très classique et euh
là on ça nous change de la pierre parce
que tout le décor est en plâtre il y a
juste les s-bassements qui sont en
pierre tu vois jusqu'à la goulotte et
après tout est en plâtre c'est 100 % du
plâtre donc tu as du plâtre qui est
moulé qui est retravaillé enfin c'est un
boulot monstrueux c'est des techniques
que malheureusement on a un peu un peu
perdu c'est un peu compliqué pour
restaurer ça maintenant
d'
c'est vrai que il y
a on est sorti de la ville et je va de
faire découvrir les villas fondais les
fondit C des artistes et puis ils
avaient ils avaient pas mal de sous et
lui était au conseil municipal et ils
ont décidé de construire un lotissement
avec 12 maisons et qui sont qui sont
complètement exubérantes
c'est belle époque c'est c'est à cette
époque qu' construit Vichy les stations
thermales les les maisons sur la côte
normande voilà ça évoque ça évoque ça
c'est l'exposition universelle de
1900 c'était l'école des filles qui
s'est construite sous sous Jul ferry en
1937 c'est un bâtiment qui est tout en
rondeur là ouais il est en écho avec les
avec les remparts et la grosse tour en
face bien
sûr et euh ça va peut-être t'étonner
mais depuis 10 ans ce monument c'est un
monument
historique tous les bâtiments qu'on
avait vu jusqu'à présent ils avaient un
toit toit bourguignon là c'est le toit
Terrass donc c'est vraiment
l'architecture du moderne du 20e siècle
il y a l'apparition du béton aussi
surtout les vents qui sont faits en
béton et c'est un mariage des deux de
pierres de béton et et de et de
verre l'histoire de l'architecture à bon
continue de s'écrire le dernier chapitre
c'est cette école que vous voyez
derrière moi école de cinéma de Clube
lelouge qui vient tout juste d'être
construite si une balade à travers
l'architecture àone vous intéresse
sachez que le conseil d'architecture
d'urbanisme et d'environnement de Côte
d'Or vous a préparé un petit guide pour
une balade à travers l'architecture à
bon depuis l'an